i'm fabiano caruana i'm here in st
louis about to play the sink field cup
the strongest tournament ever
uh this is my als ice bucket challenge i
was challenged by anish giri
and i would like now to challenge
maurice ashley
yester cerrone and levon aronian
all right one moment
hi i'm grandmaster maurice ashley and i
have been nominated
for the ice bucket challenge by my
friends
in quotes uh elliott liu amy lee who's
my business partner as
well and by grand master fabiano caruana
who is playing in
this chess tournament that i'm here for
the sinkfield cup the highest rated
chess tournament
in history so i am going to make a few
people suffer by nominating them
as well uh a friend of mine new friend
jeja wang
uh she's gonna suffer for this of course
and she said oh my god that was the
first thing she said when i said
told her she's getting nominated also
alyssa melvina who
has not replied to me as yet but alyssa
i know you're coming to st
louis so you're going to get it and also
tony rich
who is the head of the chess club here
so he's
totally pumped about it so those are my
three people
i thought this thing was really stupid
at first when i heard it my son was the
first one to tell me about it
but after i heard what the reason was i
thought well you know what it's a really
cool cause and
i'm 100 behind it to support it the only
thing i hate about this is that i'm
going to get wet and cold
which is not cool so i'm pretty angry
about this
get it out the way and let's get it done
i feel for those players